klar schaut mal was hat denn der
Weihnachtsmann hier wieder gebracht boah
das wieder an schweres Dings Teil oh ja
ja ja
wohl meine Damen und Herren seid live
dabei wenn Vanessa dieses Jahr das erste
Mal wollte jonglieren ich esse jetzt
meine erste Mandarine in diesem Jahr der
Sack hat 399 gekostet ich hoffe das sagt
dass die gut sind
oh nee die riechen schön nach Mandarine
aber kann Mandarin drauf oh
man hallo Leute wir haben Hunger und
deswegen gibt es heute den reishunger
Adventskalender und da reishunger sehr
oft mit Influenza zusammenarbeitet muss
ich hier an dieser Stelle ganz klar
sagen dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
und jetzt alle dieses Videos nicht
gesponsert ich kann nicht aufeinander
das Kind zu denken was das jetzt zu
Hause mit seiner spielkamera nachspielt
an alle Eltern deren Kinder ich so ein
bisschen versaue nicht so schlimm aber
doch irgendwie schon es tut mir leid wir
sind konsumgesteuerte Menschen wir
wollen wissen was hat das hier gekostet
90 €, ich habe überhaupt nicht
reingeschaut was da so drin sein könnte
ich wollte mich einfach überraschen
lassen einfach mal surprise ja und dann
würde ich sagen starten wir mit dem
ersten Türchen wenn es für sie in
Ordnung ist haben sie sich schön
eingemuckelt ja es ist alles P perfekt
also am sorry bevor ich jetzt damit
anfange den auszupacken also meine
Erfahrung mit reishunger ist ich mache
die Produkte ich
weiß gar nicht ob sie besonders teuer
sind ich glaube sie sind besonders
hochwertig ich habe schwarzen Reis von
reishunger weil es den einfach sonst
nicht gibt und ich mache gerne so ein
koreanischen Reis und dann nimmt man so
normalen Reis also so Sushi Reis oder so
dann macht man ein paar schwarze
körnereien im schwarzen Reis und damit
das so lila reißt ich weiß dass sie
einen guten Reiskocher haben weil wir
haben so ein Basic denn so ein richtig
basic Reiskocher aber schon basic
Reiskocher macht den Unterschied also
seid ihr nicht mehr im Topf kochen
sondern diesen Reiskocher haben ist mir
guten Reis eine Sache wollen wir noch
investigativ nachforscht ah er kostet
89,99 statt
104,99 €, das heißt dann spart 15 €,
also ich vermute dass der eigentliche
Preis 104,99 ist aber vielleicht ist
89,99 auch der Early Bird Preis ich gehe
jetzt einfach mal davon aus dass wir
hier anscheinend 15 € sparen das finden
wir mal heraus zum Design ich finde der
hat genau den gleichen Charme wie der
mymuesli Adventskalender ist würde mich
nicht wundern wenn mein Müsli und
Heißhunger irgendwie förmlich
zusammengehören weil der wirklich mich
sehr daran erinnert aber auch sehr
tolles also 3D man kann von jeder Seite
rankommen überall gibt's Türchen oben
nicht und auch nicht aber an den Seiten
und ja der sieht total weihnachtlich aus
total witzig hier mit der Oma und dem
Opa dann macht sie da fühlt sie da
irgendwie in weinen und der macht Sport
die machen hier social distancing
anstoßen und das eine Katze eine Taube
also alles dabei was man haben möchte
schön ja und jetzt machen wir das erste
Türchen auf ich dachte es ist
geht fantastisch auf geht fantastisch
auf Türchen Nummer eins
boah die das gesehen ich habe das
Türchen Nummer eins rausgezogen und dann
ist das Türchen Nummer zwei nachgekommen
boah da hat sich jemand also da bin da
wir haben hier das erste Türchen und da
ist was drauf in dieser Box findest du
neben einer ersten Überraschung auch ein
stapelkarten ein Vertrauensvorschuss
verwahre sie gut Boiler Alert schaue dir
die Karten noch nicht an mogeln ist
nicht sonst verdirbst du dir noch die
Überraschung drittens ziehe heute die
erste Karte vom Stapel wann du die
nächste nehmen darfst erkennst du am
Datum dich erwartet also jeden Tag eine
Überraschung meist wird es knifflig und
oft gibt es ein Kärtchen dazu diese
Elemente führen dich durch den
adventsabenteuer toll toll super toll
diese Karten ignoriert oder was
[Musik]
nein ich habe keine Karten übersehen
bestimmt gucken gerade die
Produktdesigner von dem Kalender des
Video und denken
da sind die Karten und was gibt's hier
noch ich hatte schon mal eine reishung
gekochpaste dieses Gut
heißhunger-koch-paste Chili Zinn keine
und die kann man verwenden für Boots
Chili und Burritos adios Pulver hallo
wirdige passte das kenne ich schon aus
ich glaube reißhunger ist sehr aus Asien
inspiriert weil wenn ich im Asia Shop
mir Gewürze hole dann ist es meistens so
eine Paste mal voll geil so und dann
nehme ich hier so eine Karte vom Stapel
1.12 ah okay spiel Spaß Spannung es ist
ein Rezept was ich heute mit der
kochpaste dann verwenden kann wir sind
so HelloFresh mäßig
raushole fühle ich mich wie das
Finanzamt für Adventskalender Hersteller
nicht kontrolliere auch ob ihre
Preisangaben sich da übereinstimmen 1:29
können Sie mir bitte das nächste Türchen
zeigen 1,29 € für eine würzpasste das
ist quasi wie Knorr und Maggi das kostet
meistens so 99 Cent ne aber gut so eine
Würzpaste scheint mir geiler aber ja ist
auf jeden Fall stylisches Türchen Nummer
zwei ist gleich
gedämpfter Bio Milchreis seht ihr den
Beutel durch
reiße den Beutel auf und ab damit in die
Mikrowelle kleines fertiger oh Milchreis
dauert so lange Originalgrößen hier
3,49 €, also dafür dass er so auf die
Tüte fertig lecker ist ja 3,49 €. ich
kann irgendwie nichts sagen ich weiß es
nicht und unser Rezeptbuch sagt toll
Milchreis Bratapfel trifel mit
Spekulatius oh mein Gott ist das lecker
oh klingt das gut
Artikel Nummer 3 ob ihr wirklich alle
richtig steht seht ihr wenn das Licht
angeht
reishunger mit Soße Apfel Zimt und
deswegen Kombi Rezept 32 wegen der Soße
bei Zimt mich Reis und dann noch eine
Apfel Zimt Soße ich glaube ich würde das
mit normalen Milchreis und dann das da
drauf machen
lecker okay was kostet sie 3,69 €.
Nummer 4
ich bin irgendwie nur so Probe Größen
jetzt sind gewöhnt und wenn ich dann da
hier schon 500 g Nudeln raus und guck
mal wie groß die ist hä das ist doch
reishunger das sind viereckige Spaghetti
cool oder viereckig Spaghetti sind doch
rund oder unsere nicht Nudeln von Reis
Hunger okay so was kosten die Spaghetti
3,69 €. ich meine es sind wahrscheinlich
sehr gute Spaghetti ne so Bio und so
aber 3,69 €. ja manchmal zu günstig
Nummer 5
ich habe immer vergessen die boah hier
sind die Mitarbeiter Leonie und Patricia
hi ich grüße Euch Spaghetti Cashew Pepe
mit Tomaten Crunch Mann ich brauche
irgendwas für jetzt schnell haben die
keine Snacks da ich habe richtig Hunger
auch toll hier auch ein Rezept schön
schön
ich lese nur so bissfestings und dann
denke ich mir hä und dann schreiben Sie
selber so was passt da komplett ich fühl
mich so als ob sie meine Gedanken
aufschreiben würden was ein bisschen
creepy ist so bisschen verwirrt war ich
gerade das ist einfach veganes Parmesan
oder Konfetti hat man da irgendwie
früher wohl zugesagt veganes Parmesan
Konfetti ja klar Pasta Konfetti klingt
halt besser ne weiß ja kein Parmesan ist
so Angst auch 3,69 € warum kostet jedes
Produkt 3,69 € bei denen auf der
Rückseite oha ein Rätsel ein Rätsel
findest du heraus welches Wort besuchen
ich dachte ich löse noch mal was aus
Spaß aber ich komme da überhaupt auf
nichts
das ist peinlich Schande
Türchen Nummer 6
Nicolaus Heißhunger gib mir ein Snack
ich bin Snack ah hier sind die Lösungen
für das Rätsel Spaghetti Eiswürfel
Chefkoch Löffel oh mein Gott man musste
die die auch nach hinten passen und noch
gerne im Himmel Himmelbett okay gut also
hier ist schon wieder irgendwo
irgendwelche Rätsel irgendwas drauf wir
machen jetzt einfach mal auf ne so es
gibt zum ersten Mal richtigen Reis
Naturreis
600 g sind 479 hier in 69 durch 3 1,16
€. oh das ist jetzt das nikolaustücher
die Leute nicht Nikolaus ja okay es ist
vielleicht irgendwie so ein Kinder also
so wie man zelebriert das sind Kinder
Feiertag aber nicht alle noch irgendwie
Kinder im Herzen Natur das langweiligste
gibt's ja Nikolaus
die Lösung vom letzten Rätsel und das
toll natürliche Nummer 7 befindet sich
wow können wir aufhören immer so
verwirrt zu sein auf der Verpackung
und lernen
ich lese ich meine verwirrten Fragen auf
der Packung Gewürz Zubereitung für
Tomatensoße danke es ist eine
gewürzzubereitung für eine Tomatensoße
das muss man da irgendwo
dazu 4,99 €, das ist aber eine Pastor
wir bleiben noch ein bisschen hier die
Nummer 8
und ich stehe nicht auf diese Beutel ich
sage euch warum ja zum Einkaufen ist der
gut aber haben wir nicht alle zum
Einkaufen schon ganz schön viele Beutel
und dann laufe ich ja nicht mit einem
Ding rum was wie ein Werbegeschenk
aussieht 5 € 49 ich habe das Gefühl so
Beutel kauft man einfach an der Kasse
wenn man sich denkt mist ich habe meine
Tüte mein Beutel vergessen und ich will
jetzt nicht ein backtüten nehmen also
hole ich ein Beutel und dann hat man
noch einen neuen Beutel ich spüre das in
der Nummer 9 ein Snack drin ist
die Nummer 9 enttäuscht mich dieses Jahr
nicht die Nummer 9 ist einfach das
Türchen was mir am meisten Freude bringt
falls ihr nicht wisst warum ich mich
immer zur Nummer 9 entscheide bring mir
Geburtstag der ist am 09.09.1993
deswegen ich habe eine Verbindung zu der
Zahl 9 ich kenne jetzt nicht den
reiswaffelkurs in Supermarkt hier kosten
die immer dran denken Bio Reiswaffeln
2,99
muss ich jetzt aber auch wirklich
probieren sieht aus wie eine Reiswaffel
mit Schoko
eine Geschmacksknospen explodieren
gerade
ich hätte jetzt Bauchschmerzen dafür ein
Kauf genommen aber die sind vegan sie
schmecken wie Milchschokolade
Reiswaffeln mit Sahne Schokoladen
okay
ja das Kärtchen zur Nummer 9 finde ich
cool
schmecken Tierchen Nummer 10 baby baby
es gibt Reis kaufen roter Reis roten
Reis habe ich noch nie gesehen 2,83 €
und hier ist das Rezept dazu roter
Reissalat mit Zitrus und Fenchel okay
das klingt ganz geil fenchel ist auch
etwas was ich viel zu selten zubereite
kennt ihr meinen asmr-kanal schon nein
dann check die Infobox oder gibt einfach
lauschwanne asmr auf YouTube
oha das ist Rapsöl raffiniert mit
natürlichem Zitronenöl und Ingwer
würzölle habe ich immer nur auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt gesehen und dann
nirgends gekauft
[Musik]
schmeckt nach irgendwas Zitrone und Öl
aber warum sollte ein Öl Ingwer nach
Ingwer Zitrone schmecken ja werde mal
wenn man so nach asiatischer Art was
anbrät dann ist so ein bisschen Ingwer
und so dann gut wenn man Kürbissuppe
macht kann man den Kürbis in Ingwer
vielleicht doch gar nicht so schlecht
und es sieht halt sehr stylisch aus ne 7
€, 49 okay Nummer 12 es ist Halbzeit im
Weihnachtsgeschäft du denkst jetzt schon
oh mein Gott die Zeit ist so schnell
vergangen 12 Tage bis Weihnachten ich
habe noch gar kein Geschenk dann ist das
reishunger Reis Topping genau das
richtige umami
das unterschätzt man auch ne wenn man
Reis kocht kann man sich hier eine
richtig schöne Würzmischung da rein
machen bisschen umrühren und dann hat
dein Reis und richtig geilen Geschmack
nice das ist hier sogar doppelt
gesichert damit die Mehlmotten auf jeden
Fall dein Reis Gewürz nicht finden 6,69
€. 13 Sushi rein Sushi Reis kann man
nicht genug von bekommen ich habe
letztens das erste Mal die liebenbach
mit Sushi Reis gemacht und dann
schwarzen Reißer zwischengemischt oh es
war geil ich dachte man man kauft nur
Sushi Reisen wirklich Sushi zu machen
aber man kann damit ganz viele andere
Gerichte essen 600 Gramm du bist 200g
1,60 €
daher der perfekt die sechs hingekonnt
und da hättet ihr ein schönes
Nikolausgeschenk reinmachen können nicht
jeder hat jemanden der einem was in
chupac klar und
radweg.de jawollo
hm
super leckere Erdnussbutter okay
köstlich heute habe ich auch Lust auf so
einen Erdnussbutter mit Marmeladen
Sandwich auf so einem ganz weißen Toast
ungetoastet natürlich
3 € 99 sehr leckere Erdnussbutter muss
ich leider gestehen also ist schon viel
besser als die die wir immer in den
Discountern geholt haben 15 was macht
die Reis was kostet
Basmatireis 1,66 €. also ich sag mal so
ne das ist der erste Adventskalender wo
es richtig sich lohnt und praktisch ist
weil das hier bei mir so eine
Massenanfertigung ist vergesse ich die
ganze Zeit die Kärtchen dazu zu gucken
Sushi Bowl mit miese Aubergine kommt
nicht nur Sushi Rollen machen sondern
auch eine Bowl am 14 haben wir Luisa
kennengelernt hallo Luisa und jetzt
gibt's hier wieder ein Kombi Rezept wir
haben gerade Basmatireis gehabt und
jetzt gibt es am 16
boah dieser Kalender sieht so viel wie
ein Wocheneinkauf bei mir kein Wunder
wenn hier mediterranes Tomatengemüse
drin ist ich liebe solche Dinge ne weil
Reis kochen okay das packe ich in meinen
Reiskocher der kocht so vor sich hin
dann mache ich mir irgend so eine Soße
warm und dann habe ich ein gutes
Mittagessen
ich liebe es zu kochen wirklich
mittlerweile mag ich auch neue Rezepte
auszuprobieren aber unter der Woche kann
ich nicht mir Sachen ausdenken die ich
irgendwie kochen möchte wenn ich mich
mittags hinstelle und kochen möchte dann
geht alleine eine Stunde fürs Kochen
Flöten der Kalender macht es uns leicht
17 ist gleich um die Ecke
reishunger Reis Schokolade Kokos Riegel
ist es ein Kokos es ist ein kokosriegel
also der beste Kokos Riegel ist von
Wiegens keine Diskussion es schmeckt als
ob man Kokos mit Butter irgendwie
zusammen gemixt hat und dann ganz fest
werden lassen hat und dann ist man
eigentlich wie so ein Stück Butter was
nach geiler Kokos schmeckt also gesund
schmeckt das überhaupt nicht
Reizung welche mit bewerbe ich mich als
Gesicht für eure Süßigkeiten vielleicht
also gerade so Schokolade und sowas das
macht ihr sehr gut das schmeckt wie ein
Original Bounty
und da steht Kurier für Timo
also für vier Stück ich habe gerade
schon gedacht 8,19 € habe ich gedacht
was Rainer kostet zwei Euro fünf
Türchen Nummer 8 10 in jedes gute Reis
mit scheiß Gericht kommt Kokosmilch dazu
und Thai Curry
Panang ich weiß was ich mit reishunger
zusammen mache immer wenn ich mit Timo
was koche dann
fragen wir was wir so essen wollen und
wenn wir was mit Reis machen dann sagen
wir mal oder wollen wir Reis mit Scheiße
und ich würde einfach eine wird Paste
mit euch machen die Reis mit scheiß
heißt ich weiß ist ein bisschen
unappetitlich auf den ersten Gedanken
aber im zweiten ist es schon logisch
seid scheißegal was reinkommt aber Reis
mit Scheiße 50 Gramm ja
1,69 € natürlich alles kostet 1,69 € und
die Kokosmilch 1,19 € tiefen Nummer 19
Miso Paste ja wieso Paste ist mega
praktisch um alle möglichen asiatischen
oder südo asiatischen Gerichte zu kochen
eigentlich nee Asia also Korea Japan ist
ja auch total eingeben alle miesepaste
oder viele viele ich sag mal viele viele
Euro
49 da guckt aber die Adventskalender
Aufsichtsbehörde du das notiere ich mich
hier ne die 7,49 €. Nummer 20 hallo noch
ein Gewürz für Curry curry ist leider
echt nicht so mein Ding ich bin bei
Curry die mag nicht den Geschmack von
Curry ich weiß indische Küche ist so
beliebt in Deutschland es gibt so viele
indische Restaurants ich kann damit
nichts anfangen ich weiß nicht warum 6
Euro 69 aber wisst ihr was dafür habe
ich das in die verlosungsbox rein denn
am Ende wenn wir alle Kalender
ausgepackt haben oder sogar ein bisschen
davor weil ich dir noch was schicken
muss na ja auf jeden Fall gibt es eine
Verlosung auf Instagram in den ich
selbst gepackt hat Adventskalender
verlose und Inhalt dieser
selbstgebackenen Adventskalender werden
all die tollen Sachen aus einer
Adventskalendern sein also hast du am
Ende ein Adventskalender mit allen
Produkten die es so gibt also hinter
diesen Adventskalender steckt auch
absolut keinen Thema es ist absolut
gender new Trill für groß klein für alle
was dabei unser Kalender ist schon in
seinen 20ern ne 21 ich will ihn mir
aufbewahren aber ich muss ihn ich muss
ihn probieren solltet Caramel oh mann ey
die schreien ja wirklich danach dass ich
dich gut finde ein kreisriges heute ist
keiner was ist das wenn ich jetzt lese
dass der Datteln drin sind ne dann
Datteln das ist wie im Daniela
Katzenberger Adventskalender das sind
halt diese typischen Dattel Matsche was
nach sollte Caramel schmeckt
ist okay aber schmeckt alles so hat
seinen eigenen Geschmack bitte nicht
verkauft hier ist einer der 150 kostet
mit Apple Cherry ich nehme jetzt einfach
die 150 Nummer 22 okay Kuckuck damit ich
bin da nicht im Malibu und teils wusste
sich Doppeln das ist die Frage hier ne
ein Euro 19 und die wird zum 1,70 €, 69
vorletztes Türchen ich rieche einen
snapchat verrückt nach Reis und
Schokolade ja ich bin noch ich bin
verrückt nach heißen Schokolade sind die
vegan
die sind vegan guckt euch diese
Schönheit an
ihr bist du eine hübsche also die
Schokolade bis jetzt immer sehr gut
geschmeckt ich habe noch Hoffnung
ich habe das Gefühl bei den Reiswaffeln
schmeckt mir die Schokolade besser es
kann aber auch sein dass die gleiche ist
mit bio-reis-pulver bio-reis-flex und
bio-puffreis sind die lecker ich habe
noch keine Punkte vergeben aber 10:50
für dieses Türchen die Seite wurde nicht
gefunden ich will auch die
reisflakeseite
3,99 € und nun kommen wir zum 24 Türchen
bis hierhin war es eine tolle Reise
es ist Heiligabend wir laufen zu unserem
Adventskalender wir haben vielleicht
noch ein reisfleck im Mund und dann
machen wir das Türchen auf
ein blitz-risotto mit Zitronengeschmack
Limited Edition das schreit doch Sommer
was wären 24 Türchen gewesen mhm die
Flakes oder die Apfel Zimt Soße ich
sag's euch das ist ein 24 Türchen Apfel
Zimt Soße aber doch nicht
zitronenrisotto ich bin dafür das
reishunger seine Adventskalender noch
mal zurückzieht und ähm das hier
austauscht 5,19 €. das ist am 24 also
ich glaube ich hatte noch nie im
Kalender der so viele große Produkte hat
also mein ganzer Tisch ist voll mit
Produkten so dann holt hier die
Adventskalender beauftragte mal ganz
kurz den Taschenrechner raus und rechnet
mal zusammen was wir hier haben 12
Sekunden später
das ist meine erste Rechnung
[Musik]
verwöhnt und blöd wie ich bin dachte ich
dass man ein bisschen mehr für sein Geld
bekommt dass das quasi so eine Aktion
ist hey hier hast du ein super
Mengenrabatt zusätzlich dass ich ja zum
Beispiel kein curryfan bin also fällt
das Curry Zeug raus vielleicht mag ich
den roten Reis auch nicht so gern
vielleicht mag ich keine Erdnussbutter
dann hat man ja immer weniger für das
was man halt bezahlt hat ich glaube halt
einfach dass hier ganz gute Produkte
drin sind also macht man jetzt einen
guten Deal mit dem reishunger
Adventskalender nein man bekommt das an
Warenwert wofür man bezahlt sind die
Produkte schlecht nein die sind
fantastisch ich liebe die
schokoreiswaffeln die Nudeln sind
bestimmt auch toll um noch mal ein Wort
für reishunger auszusprechen und
Kalender macht sich ja auch nicht von
selbst ne da muss ja auch ein Grafiker
sich das rein ausdenken dann denkt sich
jemand die Verpackung aus es war ja auch
sehr schlau gedacht mit man sieht raus
und dann fällt es runter also da haben
Sie wahrscheinlich sehr gute Leute
engagiert die das machen dann hat man ja
auch noch das Risiko dass man dir dann
so Adventskalender macht und vielleicht
bleibt man dann da drauf sitzen das
heißt man muss das gucken dass ich das
finanziell auch natürlich lohnt und das
ist mein Fazit und bevor ich jetzt noch
was anderes sage verlasse ich diesen
Raum ich wünsche euch einen schönen
Abend oder morgen je nachdem wann ihr
das Video schaut ich oh bekommt aber
sorry das ist ein Anruf